en france nous vous le disions hier dans
nos éditions la radioactivité est très
peu monté sur les appareils de mesure
pour des raisons climatiques
essentiellement cela empêche pas les
écologistes de s'inquiéter
et de réclamer plus d'informations ils
l'ont dit ce matin à roland sicard
écouter on apprend aujourd'hui que le
taux de radioactivité
temps à nouveau vers la normale mais on
ne nous a jamais dit en fait qu'il y
avait eu un taux de radioactivité trop
élevé cependant nous le savions quand
même déjà puisque vendredi j'avais été
prévenu par des travailleurs du
nucléaire qui avait fait des analyses en
heures creuses fantin sur lag et sur
flamanville et ils avaient détecté dix
fois la radioactivité naturelle donc
ce conte ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
c'est que monsieur pèlerins qui est le
chef du sc ferry du service central pour
la protection contre les lier le
rayonnement ionisant a fait de la
rétention d'informations